you ready home ya know what we gotta go  back home man why I pooped my pants just  now I just pulled my pass you got  diarrhea hell no man I ain't gay we  gotta go home right now man let me  change my drawers so maybe the dudes be  trying to smoke us right there man how  you want me to smoke somebody when I got  poop in my pants are you sure you pooped  them in my short time I saw ya yes that  is poop in my pants nasty man it's  natural man for a three-year-old not for  a hardcore gangsta see through my real  friend though you wouldn't make such a  big deal out of it  wouldn't make such a big deal is you a  grown-ass man who just miss drawers oh  snap no you did it yeah you just ripped  pants thank you don't judge you need to  get out of my car to go to the hospital  okay I see how it see I wouldn't do that  to you though never would have to do  that to me because under no  circumstances would I ever put my pants  I'm sorry I judged you apology accepted  you